this is an air tag you probably remember
these things they are really useful for
finding something you've lost but also
some Bad actors have started using it
for stalking and things like that you've
probably seen the Articles so Apple had
this feature where if your iPhone
detected an unknown air tag following
you around it would notify you so nobody
could stalk you without you knowing but
up until this week if you had an Android
phone you were still screwed because if
they threw an air tag in your bag or in
your car it would never notify you could
still get stalked but one of the under
the radar announcements from this week
from Google is that Android phones
starting this summer will also Now
notify you if it detects an unknown air
tag following you around there are
technically some third-party apps that
would already do this but you would have
to know that you're getting stocked
already to download the app and then
find the air tag so I think this is
better Google and apple actually had to
work together to make this happen and it
turned out to be a win for everybody
except stalkers
but maybe they should do it more often
because